hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're gonna be
consuming our series in the 1972 World
Chess Championship between Bobby Fischer
the Challenger and the champion buddy
Spassky this is the best of 24 game
series now through 20 games Bobby
Fischer is up 11 and a half points to 8
& a half our buddy Spassky if you get a
win that is 1 point if you to draw that
is half of points and after 24 games if
they are tied buddies Spassky would be
the champion so but he's fast he needs a
draw in three wins over the next four
games to remain the champion Bobby
Fischer if he can get two draws over the
next four games he wins if he gets one
win in a the next four games he will be
victorious so this is a game number 21
but a Spassky does have the white pieces
so has that advantage now the last six
games have all been draw so fireworks at
the beginning of this tournament but it
seems like Bobby Fischer realizes this
long as he doesn't screw anything up
allowed buddy's basket to get back in
this with a few wins he should be good
so it's just been continuous draws over
and over but that brings us to game 21
but he Spassky playing the white pieces
starts out with pawn to e4 Bobby Fischer
pawns who a c5 Knight to f3 pawn e six
pawn d4 this is the Sicilian defense
pawn to a6 now after Knight to c3 we see
knight c6 now with the pawn to a6 here
this is the Paulsen variation and then
after Knight to c3 Knight to c6 this is
a variation that Bobby Fischer has never
played before so trying to catch his
opponent off guard he's done this all
throughout the tournament so far and
leaves it to game 21 to continue to do
this as well
Bishop to e3 now usually when white
plays their Bishop to e3 before their
LightSquared Bishop this lets their
opponent know that they're thinking
about castling on the Queen side and
then attacking on the Kings side the
board not always the case but many times
you will see this happen Knight to f6
attacking this pawn in the center of the
board a Bishop to b3 so
now White's looking like could castle on
either side of the board and then pawn
to d5 so Bobby Fischer attacking
immediately in the center with his pawns
we see Spassky taking the center pawn
takes here on d5 the pawns gonna
recapture and then castle on the King
side now White has a few options in this
spot it could gas on the Kings side
could play pawn to a3
if he wants a waiting move could also
play pawn to h4 this really says I'm
gonna attack on the King side when your
opponent plays the Sicilian offense
especially once they give up give up
this C pawn they're usually looking to
castle on the King side so I love the
approach of playing pawn to h4 getting
ready to attack on the King side another
option would be Queens to e2 this opens
up the door for the bishop to move that
would be a discovered attack on the King
right here this also allows for white to
castle on the Queen side preparing for a
King side attack so since pawn to h4 is
coming Queen to a2 makes Queen to e2
makes a lot of sense but buddy Spassky
playing what I would consider more
conservatively plays castle on the King
side not looking for that very
aggressive attack on the King side of
the board
Bishop down here to a d6 this is
attacking this pawn here on h2 something
to keep in mind if things were to
develop in the center of the board
this Queen has a discovered attack as
soon as this bishop moves now it's only
defending the pawn right here but keep
that in mind as we go later into the
game then I it takes up here on c6 the
pawns going to recapture here on a c6 a
bishop here to a d4 castle on at the
King side for Bobby Fischer so we look
at this position from Spassky how would
he continue we have the rook to e1 just
centralizing getting this rook involved
into the board this makes a lot of sense
pawn to h3 if you want to have a waiting
move you don't want the Knights come
down here to g4 the bishop down here to
g4 also makes sense could play Knight to
a4 he does have the bishop here on d4 so
this opens up if he wants to bring his
Knights to a
six just putting some pressure on a
black side of the board there is a
backward pawn here on c6 three pawn
structures from Bobby Fischer so if
buddy Spassky can get his minor pieces
behind enemy lines could put a lot of
pressure on a Bobby Fischer instead
decides to play Queen to f3 so pretty
aggressive square for the Queen to get
involved into the game you usually don't
see the Queen's come out this early in
the game Bishop to e6 just playing some
defense right now
rook swings over here to e1 pawn to c5
forcing the bishop to move could come
back but decides to go ahead and take
that material Queen takes then the Queen
takes right here the pawn recapture so
after this exchange things in my opinion
are very good for Bobby Fischer yes
there are four pawn structures there's
double pawns here on the F file so if
you look at that white does have a
slight advantage but what it really
comes down to is the minor pieces the
bishop pair is gonna be so huge to
control an open board state and by open
board just there's not a lot of pawns
blocking all the the squares that these
bishops can go to so Bobby Fischer does
extremely well in this type of endgame
and it's more difficult for white to put
a lot of pressure on these double pawns
because the Queen and some of the minor
pieces are already off the board so this
is looking good for Bobby Fischer
especially knowing that really needs two
more draws the last four games it's
gonna be difficult for birdie Spassky to
find a win here unless Bobby Fischer
makes a mistake rook to d1 centralizing
the rook usually want to do this in a
game that's exactly what we see rook
here to a d8 so this is another place
where once the bishop comes down here
there is a discovered attack now with
the rook it was the Queen earlier in the
game a couple options that black had
could have brought his rook over here to
be age you want to control the semi open
files or just have it in the center of
the board to defend pieces so had a
couple options in the end decided to
play rook here to d8 the big Bishop
comes back here to e - now the rook here
on d1 is it
in the pond as well as the night here on
c3 Bobby Fischer continues with rook to
b8 attacking this pawn right here but it
also leaves open for the bishop to take
here on a6 that main I want to take it
right away the rook coming down here on
a b2 is gonna be very difficult to deal
with you never want your opponents to
get the rook here on the second-ranked
if you're white or for black over here
on the seventh ring can really just
attack all of your pawns especially if
you don't have any developed which buddy
Spassky does not so first place pawn to
b3 stopping that threat but now Bobby
Fischer has to figure out how he wants
to approach dealing with the bishop here
on YouTube it is threatening the pawn he
decides to go ahead and play pawn to c4
does not once a move his rook here on b8
still controlling the semi open file and
this does block off these light squares
that the bishop can attack here on a six
so buddy Spassky decides to go ahead and
take here on a d5 remember he does have
the rook here on d1 protecting it after
the bishop takes the rook takes up here
and it looks like Betty Spassky is up
let's hero but if you remember there is
that discovered attack with the bishop
down here to h2 always have to keep in
mind if you or your opponent is ever
having a piece where they can
immediately attack your opponent's king
if they have a piece behind that it can
easily take this piece in this example
it's the rook that's gonna fall so after
the king takes here on h2 the rook takes
on d5 now the bishop takes the rook down
here to d2
yes the pawn can fall here which it does
but then the rook can take here on at c2
so Bobby Fischer going into the endgame
absolutely has an advantage he has two
rooks which more than makes up for the
pawn disadvantage that he has so all in
all things looking up for Bobby Fischer
now this is a tough spot right here for
me buddy Spassky because he wants to
hang on to as much material as he can
but he also knows that he's under a lot
of pressure here if he moves this pawn
right here doesn't matter which square
he goes to he is going to lose the pawn
here on b3 okay well that
not really a good option here the only
way to protect this pond right here is
to play rook to e2 or it could come over
here and play rook to a-1 but rook to
a-1 has its own threats so the rook can
just come over here to f2 so he's gonna
have to exchange material rook to e2
rook takes the bishop comes down here on
to e2 now this is a better in game a for
Bobby Fischer but he does have to be
careful those now to pass pawns on the
Queen side of the board
so while he does have the better pieces
this absolutely is a tricky spot for any
player in the in game so he plays rook
to DA just centralizing allowing him to
come back here to the second rank behind
enemy lines pawn up here to a4 rook down
to d2 attacking the bishop here on
YouTube and then Bishop here to c4 now
this is a tricky position Bobby Fischer
definitely want to make sure he did not
mess this up there's a pawn here on f2
that looks enticing he also recognizes
there's the threat here on the Queen
side of the board he opts to bring his
rook to a2 just does not want any threat
of this pond pushing forward although we
could have taken this pawn on f2 it's
just tricky because you can imagine the
pawn starts to push here on a5 there's a
couple options that Bobby Fischer could
have gone here best move would be king
to f8 but after the pawn to a6 here's
the tricky move the rook really needs to
come here to be 2 it does no good if it
comes here to a2 in fact this would be a
losing position this pawn is being
protected by the bishop here on a c4 so
now this pawn can push forward it's now
attacking the rook here on a 2 so
there's really matter where it goes
because this pawns gonna push forward
here now if the King gets involved into
the game pawn up here to a b6 this pawn
on a 6 is still protected by the bishop
here on a c4 King over here to d7 pawn a
7 can't here to c6 and then the deadly
move of a bishop to d5 if the King takes
here then all of a sudden
on up to b7 that is going to eventually
promote here no way to stop that could
decide to go ahead and take the pawn
here there is an exchange and then
White's gonna have the advantage going
to the endgame yes there's a three pawn
to one pawn a situation but the bishop
is going to be able to dominate the end
of the game so if we come back that
would be very bad that's not how you
want to approach you but instead of the
rook coming over here to a2 if he comes
to rook to be two now there's no real
way for white to win this if he does
push forward with pawn to a7 well now
the work can come over a two and there's
no way to protect this pawn and if he
doesn't he can't move this pawn up pawn
to b4 is where he'd want to go the rook
can now take that the King can easily
come over here so that would be an easy
win for Bobby Fischer if he were to
swing over here right away instead of
bringing the King to f8 then just pawn
here two before attacking the rook we
see a similar situation as before so
that is how Bobby Fischer could have
continued if he wanted to that does get
him a pawn but at the end of the day he
says I'm not even gonna worry about that
I'm gonna play rook over here to a2
don't need that pawn I just do not want
to worry about this pawn pushing forward
now we see the King come a to g3 King f8
so both sides recognizing they needed to
get their Kings hidden ball to the game
nothing else really to do over here on
it the Queen side of the board King to
e7 pawn up here to g4 and then pawn to
f5 now this is gonna be a subtle move
but my opinion this is the best move in
the game for Bobby Fischer and the main
reason is he's giving up a pawn in
material but after the pawn takes the
pawn to f6 the beauty of this move is he
actually wants a pawn right here and he
wants to block that off and the reason
for that is he recognizes that this
Bishop really needs to defend these
pawns over here on the Queen side
the board bobby fischer's main way he's
gonna win this cuz his rook over here on
a - it's kind of held down right now I
can't go anywhere else unless it has a
very good reason because these pawns can
start to push his main reason of he's
going to win is pushing this pawn here
on the Kings side of the board and he
knows that his opponent really needs to
defend that with his bishop but really
to defend that correctly he needs it to
be somewhere around at this e 6 squared
depending on where the pawn goes to and
so even if he can just stop the bishop
from controlling this h3 square that is
good enough for Bobby Fischer and in his
opinion that is worth giving up that
pawn of material very very fascinating
move as you think about just giving up a
pawn in the in game but that's exactly
what he did so now the bishop comes back
here to a g8 attacking the pawn pawn to
h6 as expected here King to g3 King over
here to a d6 and then King f3 and this
is tricky because you almost really need
to play pawn to f4 and why is that okay
after King to f3 then the rook comes
down here to a1 and this is tricky
because now the rook is threatening to
come over here to g1 as soon as it comes
to g1 the King can no longer come to
this G file and that's gonna make it
much easier for the pawn over here on h6
to just start marching down the board as
we talked about this is blocking all the
squares that the bishop can go to the
King here on d6 is now Knightly
positioned so that the bishop can't come
here to defy so Bobby Fischer's setting
up everything so the pawn can push
forward so this is exactly what happened
the king came to f3 now the writ comes
down here buddy Spassky says ok now I
have to bring the King down here to g2
but now the King can come here to e5
this is still defending the square here
on d5 but it also limits some of the
squares that Betty Spassky can go to so
if we come back and we say okay how
should white continue he should continue
with ponzu F
for this stops the king coming down here
to e5 very complex in game when you look
at and see these very subtle moves but
they do have a huge impact and the game
Bobby Fischer does not make mistakes in
the in game very often he did not in
this one rook down here to a-1 King to
g2 and then the King here to e5 as we
talked about Bishop to e6 yes this is a
centralized move but as we talked about
it does not really stop this pond coming
down here on the H Phi H file Bobby
Fischer now plays King to f4 knowing
that his pawn here on f6 is safe
nothing is ever going to touch that
either these pawns really are not going
to move so just wants to put more and
more pressure on his opponents Bishop up
here to a d7 rook here to a b1 attacking
the pawn bishops got to come back here
to e6 to protect that work up here to a
b2 just adding more pressure on the King
over here on the King side of the board
Bishop down here to c4 rook to a2 Bishop
to e6 so both sides maneuvering a little
bit but then after pawn to h5 Bishop up
here d7 but he Spassky decides to go
ahead and resign there's just no way to
stop the pawn coming down here as soon
as this King moves then all of a sudden
the rook can take material right here it
just at the end of day was too much for
a British SAS key to hold on to so he
decided to resign Bobby Fischer with the
win ends up being at the 1972 World
Chess Champion and became a worldwide
phenomenon greatest American chess
champion that we've had still talk about
him to this day but that was an exciting
tournament as many people have dubbed it
the match of the century not
specifically one game but the entire
match of the 1972 World Chess
Championship so hopefully you guys enjoy
this series of going over all the games
I love doing commentary on some of the
older
more historic series there much longer
as you can see 24 games series so if
there's another series you guys would
like me to cover please let me know but
thank you so much for watching all these
videos until next time thanks for
watching and see you guys in the next
video